This is the ocean’s ‘twilight zone’.
More than 30 metres below the surface,
coral reefs still flourish in the gloom.
But these deep reefs could be under threat
from a powerful force:
Hurricanes.
Scientists have long known that shallow reefs
are vulnerable to hurricanes
with corals torn apart as the winds stir up the sea.
But the reefs of the twilight zone have been
assumedto be protected from the worst effects.
These deeper reefs have also been thoughtto
provide a temporary refuge
for shallow-reef species,whichcould
shelter in thedeeper water.
But new research is telling a different story.
Scientists in Puerto Rico have been studying reefs
both before and after Hurricane Maria,
a particularly violent storm.
They’ve already shown that the hurricane caused
currents and upwellings deep into the twilight zone.
Next they plan to assess damage to the deeper
corals directly in Maria’s path.
The deep-reaching effects of strong hurricanes
would bebad news for specieson the hunt
for somewhere toweather the storm.
Of course, coral reefs have been
surviving hurricanes for millennia
but extreme weather events are getting
more common as the climate changes.
Human activity is also causing ocean
acidification and warming.
This can lead to diseases and coral bleaching
and recent research suggests
that deeper reefs
could be just as vulnerableas shallow ones.
Coral reefsprovide coastlines
with a line of defence against storms.
Solosing this delicate resource
couldadd yet more pressure
to regions already devastated
by the effects of climate change.